all right uh next subject once i fund my
notes again here we go oh there you go
philadelphia eagles lost yesterday and
we talked about this during the show the
all the injuries and and how much of it
do you blame on carson wentz but you
know
we we we've said maybe the rams should
regret paying jared goff yeah is it fair
to ask the question of whether or not
the eagles should regret paying carson
wentz and i remember last year we had
the conversation carson wentz versus
nick foles wentz is a better quarterback
the eagles are a better team when falls
plays right they've struggled this year
i thought the biggest issue with wence
would be staying healthy he stayed
healthy he's just not effective all of a
sudden no no
and really it's it's been tough sledding
ever since desean jackson's been out of
the lineup it's just not it's not an
offense that scares you in any capacity
the run game is solid but not great you
know they have no speed at receiver al
shawn jeffrey and desean jackson are not
there
you heard me say during the show today i
do think doug peterson needs to reinvent
himself a little bit on the offensive
side of the ball i mean i'm just you
know again how many times can can carson
went smash in a seven yard completion
where the guy is totally covered and
he's got to throw it perfectly
underneath the guy's chin has not been
perfect i will say you know i get i
think it's fair to ask the question
i do think carson wentz still has
special attributes that's where i kind
of you know put him in front of a jared
goff again he's playing in philadelphia
he's been a part of a team that
certainly hasn't had brandon cook's
robert woods uh and uh who else and
cooper cup to throw to i mean there's no
he has not he's had nothing like that at
all nor has he had todd gurley a
tailback so i think he is talented i
think they see that um does he is he
perfect no did he miss some throws
certainly does he stand in the pocket
and wait too long at times for people to
come open and then it gets sacked fumble
and things like that yeah he does he
needs to get out and get out of you know
harm's way at times he's a little too
stubborn that way so it hasn't been
perfect but i'm not gonna sit here and
just go oh no it's carson wentz uh they
believe in them and i understand what
they see when they believe in him
because
we saw two years ago he should have been
the nfl mvp this is the that dynamic
that the steelers are dealing with to a
greater extent right the steelers have a
second rounder that is on the field and
do we bench him for devlin hodges do we
keep hodges in the game now that we have
benched him
the eagles gave up so much to get in
position to get wentz they can't they ca
they can't they couldn't have kept nick
falls no they had to make the investment
in wentz and they have to hope for the
best and hope that they can get the most
out of him nick foles ain't exactly
lighting up the world in jacksonville
right now either so let's not forget
that how did they win a super bowl i
mean really the planets that had to line
up for that team to win a super bowl and
to get the absolute most out of nick
foles in that spot pressed into service
after the torn acl december 2017 to to
be the one seed to be the underdog in
every game and just everything fell
together just perfectly for you it's
almost like a slumdog millionaire type
well yeah where everything falls
together just perfectly and the next
thing you know they went yeah well they
were dominant up front in those years
too we can't forget their defensive line
can take over a game their offensive
line uh was capable of just road grading
defenses and and winning it that way you
know carson once was phenomenal the
offense was still new to the nfl again
you know if you're if you're staying the
same you're getting worse that's that's
the saying in the nfl you got to
continue to evolve and i think all that
needs to be done in philadelphia and
yeah that was just a special team that
had the mojo going that year
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports